that's not the plan
um who's in charge of the artwork
because your guys's artwork is super
dope it's very consistent in terms of
like colors and I feel like Vibe like I
think that's like what caught me
initially was just like oh [__] like
because I feel like that's kind of like
your first impression for anybody you
know is that is that do you handle that
you guys handle that together that's us
collectively my manager over there like
it's something we all sit down as a team
and look at like we we discuss what we
want to like capture in a still and um
like we brainstorm on different ways to
do it you guys set up photo shoots for
that and then just go through a bunch of
options and yeah for sure yeah instead
of this this particular album cover
um it's like an erotic novel so we
wanted to like capture the the
the picture of like lusting and like not
being able to escape your addictions
right in the still frame so so that's
the theme of this new album thanks yeah
erotic now have you guys ever read any
erotic novels that's a point of
reference never never I've seen 50
Shades of Gray now yeah yeah that's all
I need terrible movie really bad like
all time bad so many [__] in there
though so I was like I'm gone
yeah definitely for the theater but the
theaters definitely I just I can't speak
to the movie it was I was expecting a
lot because the book was so popping
right no that [__] was cheeks bro that
was weird what's worse 50 Shades of Gray
or the weekend's new show
I didn't see that I saw this clip of him
being tough earlier
I just watched the first episode a
couple days ago and I love the weekend
and I hope it gets better but the first
episode was crazy what is it called the
Idol idol yeah but
early episode
50 Shades of Gray right wow that's right
that's right tie it all in yeah that's
what that's what really got me into the
weekend for sure really oh yeah but then
I chose just yeah we went Pikachu
reverse that's what I'm saying man it's
all exciting what's it like not being
black and being in a group called black
honesty
I mean I'm Cuban so like right but not
black
you're not Afro Cuban foreign
too bro I mean I I don't know I I bought
An ancestry kit I gotta spit in the tube
and send it out
I'm definitely a lot of Europe or
Ireland I think I'm Irish
German I thought Italian for some reason
I mean I could be wrong I have no idea
polish
I dated a police girl in high school her
dad was so [__] racist that sounds
about right yeah yeah sounds crazy
what's your manager over there he looks
like he could be from [__]
Scandinavia
that [__] looks like he's
related to Nicola jokic bro he looks
like he looks like he just won a chip
over there
me and him grew up together we were in
music school in sixth grade shout out to
Jersey yeah bro how far is uh what part
of Jersey is it playing where's that at
in terms of like where The Sopranos took
place and then New York City uh that's
about 40 minutes from Bergen County
where The Sopranos took place and then
there's like because I've only been I
just was in uh where did we go to shoot
with um what's that kid's name just got
out of prison that we shot a shot with
in Jersey
I'll be I'll he's on Empire
I'll be out
yeah we were in some some neighborhood
in Jersey
well we're uh Jersey City or Newark or
some [__]
I lived in Newark for a long time I
definitely texted drusky when I was
there and I'll tell you right now
because I was like drewski I'm in Jersey
is he is he from Jersey
yeah which drusky we talking about
I was in uh Jersey City
is that where we were
yeah Jersey City pretty wild out there
there was like a small it was a
different area we were in there
oh yeah he took he took uh well then he
took uh he bought a honey pack right did
he put the honey pack in the honey bun I
don't know if he did that you guys ever
have a honey pack no I don't even know
what that is really what is a honey pie
from the gas station it makes your dick
hard you put a honey pack and a honey
bun a magic honey you know what else
makes your dick hard Bluetooth go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
bootleg right now sign up you get a
month supply for free I've been seeing
that [__] same active ingredient as
Viara and Cialis and if you use the
promo code bootleg right now you get 30
days
free that's amazing that was crazy that
was like The Truman Show yeah
well you know if you go to the gas
station they have like the magic packs
of honey
and then they also have like the Rhino
pills the Blue Rhino I don't be in that
section it's it's that's where you check
out yeah like the horny goat weed and
all that all that [__] no it's the it's
the magic honey
really I should have you look if you're
like drinking and you're like look you
know I'm a little drunk I might have
whiskey dick this might not work you
just or you go to bluetooth.com keep a
blue joint deck and use the promo code
bootleg and get a month supply for free
[Laughter]
um that is crazy